hi there just before this video starts i
wanted to briefly explain
what it is about a week ago we launched
our first
new channel in two years extremities
it's about why and how the world's most
remote settlements exist
told with stunning visuals and exclusive
interviews from
these places what you're about to watch
is the first episode
it's about little bay islands a town
that for complex reasons
ceased to exist after december 31
2019 at the end of this i'm not going to
ask you to go sign up for curiosity
stream or to check out hellofresh or
anything
i'm just going to ask you if you enjoyed
this to go subscribe to the extremities
channel
and check out the two other videos there
because this
is the only one that will ever go up on
wendover productions
with that please enjoy the video
at 5 pm on december 31st 2019
the mv hazel mc-isaac pulled away from
little bay
islands on board were the last few
holdouts
of those who had called the tiny island
hamlet
home this would be the final time that
the town's regular ferry service
pushed off from the rustic collection of
snow-dusted crimson
off-white and beige saltbox homes
as it exited the protected harbor the
permanent population
of little bay islands plummeted from 54
to just
two for those on board and the two still
standing on shore
the weight of the moment hung heavy in
the air
mike parsons who along with his wife
georgina decided to stay
said of the final days that a quote
palpable sadness
had enveloped the islands although an
all but inevitable conclusion
leaving hurt this is nowhere uh
there's nothing else there you know that
but
the steel people got uh for the love of
the land where they're born on i mean
you know it is
as the ferry cut through the low hanging
fog and faded away in the evening's
dying light
and as the 2010s faded from present to
past a tiny town on a couple tiny
islands
closed a chapter of its story that had
begun some 200 years prior
what was once a boomtown gone bust was
now all
but a ghost town that day electricity
that had powered the hl strong academy
onto edna's bnb the two churches and the
dozens of hardly built homes wrapping
around the harbor
shot off unopposed by street lights and
the hum of habitation
knight and his accompanying quiet
settled over the town of two
and little bay islands became the eighth
remote community
in newfoundland and labrador this
century to permanently
relocate the abandonment of little bay
islands
and the reason this small settlement
existed in the first place is enmeshed
in the intertwined history politics and
economics of the north atlantic
all of which across centuries of
european settlement have revolved around
a rather non-descript fish
by the 2010s little bay islands a name
left plural to acknowledge the
community's straddling of both little
bay
and mack islands was on its last leg
at its height more than 500 called this
small but bustling town
nestled between the lush forest and
rocky coast
home what brought people to little bay
islands and the coast of newfoundland
had little to do with what was on land
but rather what swam
in the surrounding waters but the reason
why
settlers predominantly from europe came
to newfoundland labrador and populated
the outports
was because of the proximity to this
this lush resource of wild fish
and that continues to be the case
beginning with the paleo eskimo peoples
arriving around 1000 bce
then followed by the little passage
peoples 2000 years later
indigenous hunter-gatherer societies
were the first to recognize the wealth
of newfoundland's teeming coasts
not long after the little passage
peoples had arrived though these waters
became
a bit busier northern and western
europeans were next
to identify the region's oceanic
potential and unlike contemporary
explorers
they weren't there for god but for god
simply put a cod when uh in my time i
grew up and
previous to that card was king cod's
prominence
its centrality to life in little bay
islands and newfoundland more broadly
spans well beyond wilford's lifetime
going back not just generations
but centuries when norse sailors landed
on newfoundland hundreds of years prior
to columbus's crossing
they skirted from one cold barren shore
to the next
with little more than the prevalent
easy-to-catch high-end protein fish to
fill their caloric
needs for the europeans that followed
cod didn't just represent a calorie
dense source of sustenance
but a resource with which they could
turn a profit
although british and basque fishing
ventures kept tight lips about their
favorite spots
it's likely that enterprising vessels
cut across the atlantic
alongside and even before columbus and
john cabot
in the 1490s once cabot had come across
newfoundland though the secret was out
as the explorer exclaimed that these
faraway waters were so well stocked that
all one had to do was stick a basket in
the ocean and it fill
with fish while the european explorers
carried with them
a penchant to exaggerate cabot's
description of fishing in the northwest
atlantic
maps rather accurately onto the
disposition of the atlantic
cod an onnovorious bottom feeder cod are
both perpetually lethargic
and ceaselessly hungry and as such
gladly take bait
and don't put up much of a fight once on
the line properly treated
cod keeps too and
uh cod one thing about cod
was all salt put under salt back there
then
so i mean you could keep it for a long
long time year two year or three years
if you want to i don't know how long you
could if you really need it
but usually it was cut split and
soldered
and then taken back uh to
england and portugal and spain countries
that as catholic
were eager to find alternatives to
warm-blooded meats during lent
as the fish gained popularity across
europe becoming a staple in markets in
the 1500s
and appearing in the pages of cervantes
don quixote zola's the belly of paris
and dumas's legrand dictionary cuisine
european settlements took a route along
the rocky shores of the continent's
northeastern coast
these hardy self-reliant coastal
communities
now known as outports drove the growth
of newfoundland from the 1700s onwards
built on and around the water little bay
islands
only accessible by boat angling out to
the rich waters of the notre dame bay
and the grand banks beyond but hugging
the fragmented and protective coast of
newfoundland
was the quintessential outport the
earliest census of little bay islands
dates to 1825
but some locals like wilford bartlett
believe that british fishers
may well have established year-round
habitation on the islands decades prior
weather settled in the 1820s or the
1720s
little bay islands embodies the era of
fish-fueled european expansion
and without an abiding climate or much
in the way of arable land for
agriculture like its southern relatives
off of cape cod
little bay islands from its inception
would remain
a strictly ocean-oriented economy
from the 19th century to the mid-20th
little bay islands
enjoyed a period of blissful stasis
by 1950 the town along with the rest of
newfoundland
had become a part of canada had added a
few more salt box homes
a couple new processing plants and was
sheltering more modern boats in its
harbor
but still little bay islanders went out
each day
to work their corner of the cod industry
at day's end
they picked their kids up from the
schoolhouse and headed over to their
local union meetings
when they had a chance they caught up at
the poacher's lounge
for a drink when they made it to the
weekend they headed to the crowded
grocery stores
and crammed into the towns to churches
when winter turned to spring they
planted root vegetables in home gardens
awaiting the peak summer fishing season
and when they tired
after a long career they handed their
work off to their children
at mid-century little bay islands still
happily revolved
around the same industry it always had
but while change isn't always continuous
it is inevitable and soon
intruding engines of change showed up
right
off shore it came in the shape
of a 280 foot british fair tree trawling
vessel appearing off the coast of
newfoundland
in 1951. alongside an invading fleet of
smaller trawlers from across
europe the soviet union and japan this
would change cod fishing forever
while outsiders weren't new as fishers
from as far as portugal seasonally
visited little bay islands
the technology was uh then
uh all of a sudden the dragers got
involved where you could drop
a nit over the stern of a border over
the side first side trawlers
and going drag the bottom over and
whatever is in front of that net
certainly comes up there's nothing left
and not only were we taking out a card
but we were taking a lot of bycatch too
because i mean if you add a lot of cod
and there's other things in there we
used to throw that back in the ocean
dead
in just a decade traditional methods
used by local fishers for generations
hook and line nets cod traps were
superseded by floating cities capable of
hauling up
tons of fish and flash freezing them all
while still
at sea at the same time that massive
ships consolidated the fishing industry
politicians sought to consolidate
canada's coastal population
in an effort to save on expensive
government-provided services
ferries power healthcare the
centralization program of 1954
and the fisheries household resettlement
program of 1965
moved thousands from remote outports to
population centers
in the 1950s and 60s the waters around
little bay islands had become
overcrowded
and towns not so different from it began
feeling pressure
to relocate but not only did little bay
islands persist
during this period it thrived its
docks shops processing plants churches
and school
hummed with activity for the moment
there were enough fish to support both
the cities at sea pulling it in by the
ton
and the town's continued small scale
operations
that moment however proved fleeting with
innovation
mechanization and the ruthless pursuit
of efficiency
came disaster by the 1970s
annual fish halls were tripling the
tonnage of those from three decades
prior cod populations couldn't keep up
with collapse on the horizon canadian
officials took action
turning back foreign vessels and placing
quotas on the fish
but it was far too little far too late
by 1990 in some spots one could hardly
find the fish
at all because i fished up labrador cost
500 miles north from where i lived
and they had more time up there for two
years couldn't get a card to eat
but you know it was uh like i said
nobody lesson
in 1992 the canadian government banned
nearly all cod fishing the moratorium
aimed to revive the stock over the
course of a few
years today nearly 30 years later
the moratorium is still in place
the collapse of the cod industry put
little bay islands
in an impossible position the town was
the town is in many ways a
picture-perfect
fishing community little by one this is
one of the most beautiful
communities around it's uh
it's a beautiful harbor there
in fact there's two inlets there you can
small ball one end and big bust for the
other
it was an oil and up off a harbor that's
what it is
and there's no eyes so bad the weather
gets is still sheltered
and i guess that's one of the reasons
why it's not a very big island people
had to go off the island uh
and get enough wood to keep their stoves
going and for ship building that kind of
thing because
uh according to islands out there it
wasn't it was a small line
but it was located to the fishing ground
i said i was the main thing
now though the most important fish was
gone
as an industry fishing didn't line the
pockets of little bay islanders
it didn't create massive financial
wealth but it did support
a unique way of life it nurtured the
small town camaraderie that only blooms
after decades of waiting together in the
same lines
singing the same hymns and drinking the
same draft beers
it furthered family bonds as mothers and
fathers taught their trades to daughters
and sons
as the rest of the world moved towards
urban centers little bay islands offered
an alternative path for those enchanted
by a rural
rugged lifestyle deeply entangled with
the surrounding
landscape fishing made it possible
and little bay islands had stayed loyal
the town had no backup plan no
alternative industry to pick up the
slack
should something go awry here cod
was king and now cod
was dead while fishing stayed a
consistent economic driver for centuries
the actual day-to-day practice has
proved dynamic
requiring flexibility and at times
mobility
so resettlement is as much a part of
outport life
in the province of newfoundland labrador
as the fishing that that brought people
there
in the first place some the earliest
seasonal fishing parties and later
families relocating in search of better
home bases
moved by choice others indigenous
peoples and outpour communities deemed
too far from urban hubs were pushed
or forced to relocate while little bay
islands had dodged resettlement by
choice or force for well over a century
by the late 90s it was becoming
difficult to ignore
the creeping thought that their time to
pull up stakes
was quickly arriving in the years
following the moratorium
little bay islanders turned their
efforts to crab fish and kaplan
fish that have kept newfoundland's
economy afloat through
to today yeah so while the east coast
cod fishery collapsed
what's popularly known as the cod
moratorium happened in july of 1992
and is still underway today i think what
people don't realize
is that this is still a billion dollar
industry
fisheries and in the decade that
followed
you had 10 percent of the population of
newfoundland labrador move away
as little bay islands fishers moved to
the mainland to find work
institutions that relied on their
presence the grocery stores
churches and school began to falter
in 2009 the crab processing plant
the town's last major employer shuttered
leaving the women who worked the plant
little choice but to relocate or rely on
unemployment programs
in just a few decades the bustling town
with boats whizzing past its dwarves by
day
and the poachers lounge filling to
standing room only by night
had taken on a melancholy quiet
as families peeled out of town one by
one the murmurs of
whole scale resettlement gained momentum
in newfoundland and labrador the term
resettlement
is a loaded one i don't know uh
resettlement is a bad word for me i mean
we did that
back in joey's father's day and it was a
terrible thing to do uprooted people
that you know that
was there all their lives and then
didn't approve their a bit one bit in
the world
in the wake of the cod collapse the
government revived the unpopular
mid-century policy
in 2010. this time around the
resettlement program
offered a proportionately larger payout
prohibited the provincial government
from initiating the process
and if viable required the community to
approve the decision by a 90
vote still more amenable terms aside
such a move was bound to hurt but i
think the reason why it really strikes
an emotional cord
in newfoundland labrador is because
it feels like the death of this way of
life
and so you know i felt that even when we
sold my grandfather's home in little bay
east
on the southern shores of newfoundland
labrador
you know here i had this physical link
to a community that
my ancestry was tied up in for hundreds
of years
and then you know for that to be gone
and to not be able to have that physical
link to a place that i remember growing
up and you know going with my father to
his childhood home and beach combing
along the beach and being able to go out
and dory with
my my family members you know to have
that
access pulled is more than
you know let's do something different
next year's summer vacation
it's it's this connection to place and
culture and heritage and tradition and
so i think that's difficult for people
opportunity created little bay islands
when opportunity died the town was bound
to soon follow as the grand banks
clogged with oversized trawlers and
fishing transformed from a timeless
profession to one with an expiration
date
outport youth began to look west for
opportunity
often that's what has happened no jobs
one time and the fish is going to go oh
i even summertime when you're out of
school well you got a job at a feast
plant
working in the fish plant or you wetting
the boat with your father or went down
on the dwarf cut out tongues you might
live but now there's nothing fun to do
come out of school there's no very few
places pick up a job in newfoundland and
labrador today
in many cases their own families urge
them
to move on absolutely i mean my
grandfather was the last fisherman in
our family
and that wasn't by accident that was by
design you know my grandfather
and my grandmother wanted to make sure
that their four boys
had an education and certainly
newfoundlanders and labradorians
are all educated whether that's on the
land and sea or in a classroom
but they very much wanted their four
boys to receive a classroom
education and to go on and have careers
that
allowed them to leave the outpours as
the hope that the fishery would soon
recover faded
little bay islands families and youth
made their way to the mainland
leaving behind an aging population
deeply tied to the landscape
but unmoored from economic opportunities
and far
from medical services with the
processing plant shuttered
the school empty the local bar dry the
fire department closed
and the town doctor long gone little bay
islands
in 2015 was a shell of its former
self for the 95 aging full-timers
45 minutes away from medical facilities
and grocery stores
assuming fair weather the time had
arrived to put resettlement
up for a vote the result 85 votes for
10 against missing the required 90
benchmark
by 0.5 percent
four years and zero miracles later they
voted again
this time it was unanimous little bay
islands
would resettle in the months following
the vote
little bay islanders soberly planned
their next move
packed their belongings and in some
cases
converted their homes to operate
off-grid anticipating summer
visits in addition to the 250 000
canadian
dollars little bit islanders were to
receive for relocating
they retained their property gone though
were the costly
government supplied amenities no more
power
no more snow plowing and no more ferry
service
those with unwavering bonds to the place
where they grew up
where they raised families where they
felt at home would be back
but it wouldn't be the same it couldn't
be
as the mv hazel mc-isaac disappeared
into the december night
and the parsons ducked back into their
newly off-grid home to ring in the new
year
little bay islands entered an era both
foreign
and familiar over were the centuries of
permanent settlement
and decades of direct connection to
mainland canada
returning though was the remoteness and
self-deficiency
that defined the outports earliest days
a uniquely disconnected way of life
that drew many to the islands in the
first place
in recent years seasonal visitors sea
kayakers photographers authors and
artists
have descended upon the striking
landscapes and quaint coastal
communities
of the likes of little bay islands but
fishermen like winford bartlett
and grandchildren of fishermen like jen
thornhill verma
aren't yet ready to agree to the devil's
bargain that tourism
presents back my family still lives
there as much as i'm proud that people
go there to visit
i want people to go and stay for a long
time not just a good time
staying for a long time though requires
a healthy
fishery a healthy fishery requires
something that newfoundland outpour
communities
can't procure on their own future
forward
stringent protective fishing policy at
the national
and international level outports today
will built on a foundation of
enterprising and independent spirits
bend to global forces but then again
little bay islands and outports like it
have
always been at the mercy of economics
and politics
well beyond their wharfs spanning the
northern atlantic
and beyond it's likely too late for
little bay islands
but this doesn't have to be the end for
outports
the lesson of little bay islands is not
that these places rural
small town lifestyle can't exist instead
it's that it can't exist in a vacuum
while proudly independent and situated
well on the periphery
the survival of these extremities hinges
on their relationships and ties
to the center and while the people of
outports get to decide when they
resettle
it's much larger forces that will decide
if they have to i really hope you
enjoyed this video
as a reminder this was the pilot episode
of our new channel extremities
and this is the first and last ever
episode of extremities that will go up
on wendover so if you enjoyed this
please go subscribe to extremities at
the link in the description
to get all of our future videos